miranda cosgrove just posted the first
on-set photo from the icarly revival
try not to freak out
[Music]
yep on wednesday the 27 year old actress
shared this shot with her co-stars
nathan kress and
jerry traynor it's really cool the
actors who starred on the nickelodeon
sitcom from 2007 to 2012
are gearing up for the show's reboot
which was announced in december
nathan also shared the snap writing in
the caption
my people while jerry hilariously
cautioned fans to
prepare yourselves oh we're trying
i'm excited okay so if you didn't watch
icarly back in the day
here's a little breakdown the whole show
was about carly shea played by miranda
who had a popular web series called
icarly
alongside her bestie sam puckett played
by jeanette mccurdy
i started the show when i was 13 and i
still get just as excited when people
come up to me and say they like episodes
or that they love
the show um just because it's it's
really sweet and when people say like oh
i watched your show with my
my mom yesterday and we cracked up like
it's just a really good feeling
nathan portrayed freddie benson carly's
neighbor and the show's tech producer
while jerry appeared as carly's older
brother and guardian
spencer you thought a criminal broke in
our house
and was in my room so as a weapon you
brought a suck duster
sure did the cast of the new show which
will stream on paramount plus
the soon to launch rebrand of cbs all
access
is currently missing jeanette who
previously starred in the spin-off sam
and kat
opposite ariana grande i'm back
where you've been you're in the bathroom
forever noah monk who played carly's
friend gibby gibson
is also nowhere to be seen although
producer jay cogan tweeted last month
that the show has approached noah
he also added that when it comes to
jeanette joining the reboot or not
is simply her call
[Music]